a 2700 talented kid in the rise couldn't  produce uh he got a good position  against Magnus it was a very very good  game it was probably an inspired game  you could call it but is it an obvious  proof of cheating definitely not I don't  think he cheated in the same field cup  but everything else is still sorry sorry  Alejandra I just have to interrupt you  because the game started  um and Magnus has logged off what just  happened Magnus has resigned  Magnus has to resigned the game against  how's name on  yes yes uh at least that's what it says  in our transmission  yes  it looks that way  wow  shocked yeah I mean as soon as we saw  Magnus appear on the webcam I thought  okay we're in for a game at least uh  this will help things blow over let's  focus on the chest again but  what do we say now  um this is uh this is a bigger statement  in the tweet I think